I like coffee and I like like English
breakfast tea coffee I generally go
americano because it's America and the
name and and and I have some cream and
no sugar but I do sure I do cream and
sugar and my English breakfast tea
because that's the way it's meant to be
generally I like a big desk I have a
keyboard which is one of the original
Microsoft natural keyboards which was
from like 1996 I think they changed them
after that and they have the arrow keys
that are that are an X I guess or a
cross or a plus sign rather than the
inverted T those ones are terrible but I
have like three of the classic Microsoft
natural keyboards usually like one big
monitor is my preference at this point I
have a Mac next to it and then I use
software called synergy which lets you
move your mouse cursor from one monitor
on one computer to a monitor on another
computer which is pretty helpful when
you're doing cross-platform
I think most of my work happens at home
and it used to be the kind of thing
where I would work late at night but in
the last few years I've definitely found
myself getting more done in the mornings
as I try to get up in the mornings which
i think is healthier for me in general
but yeah I think there's a lot of
there's a lot of work there's a lot of
not working but thinking about working
and sort of having problems in your mind
that you're trying to figure out the
solution for before you even go and type
any of it there's a lot of typing things
and then realizing what you're doing is
stupid and then revert you know throwing
it all away and I think that's something
that's very useful to be able to do is
to try things and then if they don't
work out to move on
yeah I tend to listen to music I was
reading something recently where they
were talking about how music that with
lyrics will affect people if feel like
people are kids are doing homework it
interferes with reading and I would tend
to agree with that but I think code is
different enough from from reading that
lyrics aren't really a problem
yes it's funny you ask that really yeah
I think I think the right amount of
procrastination is a good very good
quality because I think sometimes you'll
you'll go and have an idea to do
something and then do it and spend a lot
of time on it and then release it and
then you'll be stuck with it and then
you'll later on realize that you should
have done it a different way and now
you're stuck with the current version
it's less of an issue if you just try
something out and then don't like put it
into a release product but when you
actually release things you end up
having this pressure of not taking away
things that people like and some
procrastination is good for that and and
also I think if you really really think
things through it will save you time in
the end when you go to actually
implement
we shipped a default mp3 with one F for
a while that was win f it really whips
the llamas ass and and then there was
also an Easter egg where you can make
the title bar show that and the origin
of that is someone emailed us way back
when and I think emailed my friend Tom
pepper who was ran all of our web stuff
and was very much instrumental and
creating a lot of these communities
someone emails saying wait a it whips
the llamas ass and so it just kind of
stuck and then it turned out later that
it's actually something that wesley
willis whose i guess a comedian or a
musician or it's kind of complicated if
you look him up mostly a musician but
it's something that he would say in a
song i think i think someone emailed
that quoting one of his songs and then
it we just sort of liked it as far as
what we stood for i guess
well llamas are very cute but i don't
just just kind of having some sort of
identity and and having to be a little
weird